all right so you you've been to Iraq and
Iran right let's talk about Iran let's
all talk about Iran there's a question
that's been asked since the Republicans
took over which is can they govern I
would say no and this letter to the
Iranian leadership that was sent by the
47 Republicans this week I mean was
called by not just liberals but the
Daily News called it true traitors the
that's an FSB the Senate historians
office looked into trying to find
another example where one party was
trying to deal with the foreign policy
against the policy of the president they
could not if this was a Democratic
president can you guys honestly tell me
I can yeah no I think that it was a
mistake but I tell you Nancy Pelosi as
Speaker of the House 2007 with Bashar al
Assad in Syria and Damascus said that
Damascus is the road to peace as the
Syrian regime was providing essentially
safe haven to al Qaeda in Iraq cells who
were killing American soldiers do you
think that's an equivalent I speak of
the house I do yes I do I don't defend
the letter but I do think you're in
Speaker of the House you're third in
line to the presidency and you go and
tell Bashar al-assad who has killed
hundreds of thousands of innocent any
whiskey down our ally at that time know
what yours is
in 2007 here we are in this situation
what even John McCain has acknowledged
this was a mistake this is a this is a
situation where John McCain said that
they were in a hurry there was a
snowstorm they were trying to get home
so they just kind of signed this letter
so not even the people who signed it are
defending it anymore this was a sort of
a nightmarish situation which I think
absolutely proves that Republicans are
not ready to govern at the moment right
I think you're going to disagree
I feel like you could argue it both ways
and I can see arguments on both sides
but I feel like what they did as a
co-equal branch of government is
equivalent to what the President did in
deciding he had a moral imperative to go
it alone on things that are important to
him that Congress may not agree with you
Eve to think that the president is right
in doing that and that Congress did the
same thing that they have an equal right
or you think that Congress is wrong and
that the president as a co-equal branch
of government also should be wrong to
take that but actually in this case
they're not a co-equal branch of
government it's very clear that they got
it wrong Congress is a coherent branch
of government the executive the Senate
does not right if I treat this you know
they said that if they got ratify the
treaty they're just gonna say what they
said in the letter which was wrong
listen it was absolutely when a young
William Jefferson Clinton I was at
Oxford and protesting the Vietnam War
and then later ran for president of the
United States they said that he was a
traitor for protesting from foreign
shores and the moment that that letter
arrived in Tehran they were protesting
from foreign shores and in fact under
their their I think that where we should
be looking at this is not in terms of
treason but mutiny and I think perhaps
criminal could I ask this question I
mean I saw Lindsey Graham I think I'd
Meet the Press one of those shows and
they asked him if he feared
I ran more than Isis and he clutched his
pearls as he always done and said
absolutely it's not even close and this
idea that Iran is not just an adversary
but the incarnate of evil and an enemy
not an enemy for ever and I just think
that's wrong I mean I don't I'm not
naive about Iran they do some crazy
almost always Muslim vice has a
great episode coming up about gays in
Iran I mentioned it there they're
illegal they hang them and therefore
lots of gay people what's the solution
they have a sex change operation there's
there's a solution being gay cut your
dick off okay but lots of Muslim
countries do like that it's
a deal-breaker for American Saudi Arabia
lots of other places this idea that Iran
which also unlike many Muslim countries
has a sophisticated population that we
could bring over to a more reasonable
place this to treat them the way we
treat them just seems terribly wrong and
stupid my question is why is anybody
still listening to Lindsey Graham I want
our cuz they book why is the no statute
of limitations on stupidity right now
going back there isn't going back to
2003 I went back and so what he was
saying on me to press then and he was so
cheerleading the war she kept saying of
course Saddam Hussein his weapons of
mass destruction all the same stuff that
he's saying now but Iran without any
reservation he was saying about Iraq and
he doesn't see the connection between
what we did in Iraq and how that
strengthened Iran and how of course the
the way that Isis was Westra was created
was because of the complete failure of
having a political solution in Iraq as
we come to this country I'm skeptical
about the nuclear deal but the military
option I think it's real I think it has
to be considered and I know a lot of
people don't but it's a bad option
ultimately if we can get diplomacy to
work we should try that because the
concert when he was getting good but
here's the thing but but that doesn't
mean and I know you're saying it as well
that you know be astute to Iran's
relationship but that the Iranian
political strategy as much as we should
absolutely be trying to empower those
people under 30 they're educated
connected with the west population of
Iran we also have to be astute to the
hardline we Qasem Soleimani who's the
leader of the kurds force the Iranian
Revolutionary Guards external action
unit in Iraq at the moment they
essentially have displaced the
government in Iraq that they are
attempting to expand their front is you
see what they do in Beirut for example
car bombing politicians who don't agree
with them the problem that that causes
and why it relates back to us and it's
not just a Muslim on Muslim issue is
that it feeds into the narrative that
empowers groups like the Islamic state
al Qaeda because it feeds Sunni a sense
of Sunni disenfranchisement so they go
to war and is the nuclear that's already
happened I mean the the line in the
letter that got the Iranians or
angry was you may not fully understand
our constitutional system very
condescending they do the people who
don't are the Republicans in our own
government
Marco Rubio spent a whole day before I
saw him he doesn't understand Isis he
doesn't get it that the people who were
fighting now basically on our side are
the Iranians we're both fighting Isis
the people who are trying to take over
to Crete it's mostly Iranian soldiers
the general is right there they are
trying to take it over like exactly and
Cupid perceives us invading I know but
Iran but it won't stop there that's the
problem that if the big regional we got
rid of Saddam Hussein and and you guys
probably let me get this but that is a
it's a line of argument that do you
unleash the bottleneck but also the
problem is that the implication of this
letter is that if there is a Republican
in the White House next they're going to
go to a war okay and there's absolutely
no accountability for how they're going
to pay for it or what that means it's
like it's we've spent about four
trillion dollars on the two wars Iraq
and Afghanistan not to mention what
we're spending on the vets so now it's
like now we want to ask them how are you
going to pay for war with Iran know that
it's not North Korea they have malls
with Nike stores you've been there right
maybe not to the Nike store but North
Korea no not North Korea but Iran yeah I
mean I know people have been it's not
know in fact yeah it's a country that
during the time of the Iraq war where
they lost a million of their principally
men and the country and out of a
population of about fifty fifty five
million at that time that's an enormous
number and that's really where the
division line is in the generations so
now as the Israelis and some of these
members of Congress will often say these
are the least trustworthy things that
the pressure is on because the
generation of incredible progressive
thinking some of the most progressive
thinking in terms of separation of
church and state you will ever find is
in the young
people on Turan University and lots of
and and for us to alienate that right
and and the military option of course a
military option is always perceived very
dangerously perceived as a winnable
military option but in this case of
course we're also talking about
something that's much bigger than the
conversation of Isis versus Iran test it
finally has to do with regional dynamics
and nuclear proliferation issues if the
Waziristan boys decide to do it again in
Mumbai about soup nuclear countries
against each other so when you have an
executive branch much more worried
negotiating on that highest level for 47
senators to do this is to risk our
children's lives all right